[Music]
this morning on the dish
a journey through the history of food
with one of the most famous food writers
in the country
mark bittman's written dozens of
cookbooks but now he's out with
something different
it's called animal vegetable junk a
revealing look at how our diet has
changed for better and worse over
thousands of years it's also a call for
what bittman thinks
should come next pick the one
most important factor in shaping human
history
war disease money
mark bittman says it's food it's a story
that needed to be told i feel that we uh
it's silly to say people don't think
about food of course we all think about
food all the time we don't take it
seriously
in his new book animal vegetable junk
a history of food from sustainable to
suicidal
bittman traces the progression of our
modern diet from hunter-gatherers to
today's monolithic
industrial farms that dominate global
food production
he argues there have been three historic
stages of sustenance
the birth of growing the 20th century
and he says change somewhere
on some fertile acre the plow
knifes through soil that abounds in
promise
food no surprise really changed when
humans were able to move beyond hunting
into farming bittman says the industrial
revolution
transformed farms into factories led by
inventions like john deere's
steel-bladed plow in the 1830s a century
later
modern machinery helped free up 70
million acres of land for food
production
the right amount of tractor power is the
answer to increasing the profit
in a large farming operation at the same
time scientific innovation
increased yield america now had a
surplus of food
and another emerging industry television
to help sell it whenever you see that
gold medal sack being used
that was supported by a department of
agriculture that devised a nutritional
system
around the surplus bread and butter are
margarine
milk and cheese meat and eggs vegetables
and fruits to help make the most of
these wonder years
serve nutritious wonder enriched bread
white bread
fortified with vitamins to replace the
highly nutritional but easily spoiled
whole grains
quickly became the norm there's two
kinds of agriculture
you can grow food to sell it in which
case you don't really care what it is
because you're just selling it all you
want is
am i making more money selling this than
that and that tells you the answer
or you can grow food to feed yourself or
feed other people
and that's a that's a dividing line our
first
dish is a good example of early
agriculture this is a
sort of mayan inspired or meso-american
inspired stew you know
a form of farming called milpa or three
sisters and the three sisters are corn
squash and beans
the corn grows straight up it provides a
pole for the beans
and the squash provides shade to retain
moisture for everything
and the beans help fix nitrogen in the
soil so it's a it's a
they're a kind of cover crop so those
three things can be grown together
quite sustainably and this
is better than
that i mean this is the perfect
representation of 19th and early 20th
century
processed food you have your white bread
so you have bread that's completely
devoid of nutrients except for whatever
nutrients you put back in
if your industrially produced meat uses
resources disproportionately
encourages the growth of corn and
soybeans and very little else
you have cheese a direct result of the
dairy surplus
and then what do we do with it oh here
we'll do this
a public health disaster represented by
a cheeseburger but
don't get mad at me it it tastes good i
know you love it
i like cheeseburgers too trust me it's
not a problem
we learned to like cheeseburger i grew
up eating cheeseburgers
ever since 1921 people have enjoyed
white castle hamburger easy food like
this has been advertised almost non-stop
for decades
i'm not hungry you're having one more
bite one more bite
efforts to regulate what can or cannot
be marketed specifically to kids have
largely been ineffective
especially now that they do most of
their viewing on streaming devices
no one's really regulating what food
companies market to kids online
before they're really capable of knowing
the difference between right and wrong
that good food fun food comes in
colorful packages
sold by cartoon characters and usually
contains a lot of sugar
until we start teaching four-year-olds
what real food is
how to eat it how to enjoy it what it
takes to prepare it
then we're going to have 40 year olds
who are conflicted about
oh i know what good food is but i grew
up eating
fruit loops and and sometimes you just
want a bowl
all of that brings us to bittman's third
and final stage in food history
change in a way you could see it all as
a great experiment
how is a human race of six
seven ten billion people going to
support itself
and that question in a way has been
answered we can produce enough food
for those people now the question's a
little more refined
how do we produce enough food for those
people and make them healthy
all of them or most of them and how do
we produce enough food
for those people and not destroy the
planet
those two questions have to be answered
in the next
x years which is why today obesity and
its related illnesses is a much bigger
problem for most of the world than
than hunger is which is not to say
hunger is still not a problem
in some places but that's the big
question is how do you get kids
on that track of like eating the best
stuff
real food real food a bowl of loops is
still okay every once in a while we
most people still like cheeseburgers but
generally speaking
how do you how do you balance it out
right well so much of our food
oh it's not good for the planet